demain la cour européenne des droits de
l'homme examinera à huis clos la demande
de libération de maurice papon long
janvier dernier robert badinter se
prononcer pour sa libération anticipée
ce soir dans le journal le monde
monsieur badinter persiste et explique
sa position
cette victoire de l'état de droit de la
justice doit s'accompagner à mon sens
d'une autre victoire celle de l'humanité
sur ses bourreaux avec yasmina farber et
florence bukiya nous avons voulu évoquer
cette question en sollicitant plusieurs
témoignages contradictoires
vingt ans maintenant que cette vieille
dame va au devant des jeunes dans les
collèges et lycées
et quand l'actualité le lui suggère
lucie aubrac l'une des mémoires de la
résistance modifie un peu ces
interventions qui s'était papon c'est ce
qu'ils savent de maurice papon
c'est qu'il est en prison pour avoir
fait des portes et beaucoup beaucoup de
juifs etc aujourd'hui pourtant par le
dos les libérer à cause de son grand âge
de le voir mort et en présence est vrai
que ça va scandaliser après donc ça va
se retourner contre les légistes même si
c'est ce qu'ils ne font rien
puisque la façon dont ce trophée mais
reste en prison et nourrir rabat comme
ça il va avoir ce qu'il a fait aux
autres et est tout simple maurice papon
est le seul complice de crimes contre
l'humanité incarcéré aujourd'hui en
france
une singularité qui alimente les prises
de position sur sa libération
klaus barbie paul touvier sont morts en
prison au nom de la mémoire et de
l'histoire
papon doit-il connaître le même sort
papon a été condamné pour complicité de
crime contre l'humanité
qu'ils soient libérés ou non cette
condamnation subsistent ls a pu ainsi sa
punition il est frappé d'une indignité
sans précédent c'est pas la peine d'en
demander davantage et de voir qu'en plus
le ils soient maintenus en prison à 90
ans
ceux qui le veulent qu'est ce qu'ils
veulent ils veulent peut-être se montrer
meilleur que les français d'époque mais
ils sont pas meilleures il ne leur est
pas donné à eux de résister ils ne sont
exposés rien le nazisme est mort il ya
50 ans et puis attention
moi j'ai très peur si vous voulez dans
ces matières du conformisme il ya un
moment où on désignait les juifs et tout
le monde se précipitait pour dire ce
sont les coupables qu'il n'y ait pas le
même la même veulerie le même suivisme
dans notre attitude vis-à-vis de papon
autant de considérations qui choque
charge goldman lui avait 10 ans quand la
police française la police de papon l'a
arrêtée avec sa mère il a eu de la
chance
pas elle elle est morte a grossi et je
trouve ça d'une imprudence allait
s'adresser à la cour européenne des
droits de l'homme lui qui les a tous
bafouer les droits de l'homme les droits
de la femme les droits de l'enfant les
droits du vieillard il a tout bafouée et
c'est lui qui va demander réclamer
justice comprend pas
maurice papon à 91 ans il est l'un des
trois détenus les plus âgés de france
c'est à ce titre que plusieurs
associations accepte l'idée qu'il ne
purge pas ses dix ans de prison jusqu'au
bout c'est pas pour que l'on traite le
problème de maurice papon tout seul je
suis pour que l'on traite le problème de
tous ceux qui sont actuellement détenus
dans des conditions d'une humanité
s'il meurt en prison ils veulent venir à
martyrs et martyr il y aura un
pèlerinage aura une attention spéciale
des avis ce vieillard et qui deviendra
non pas le bourreau de plus de 1000
personnes mortes en déportation mais la
victime d'une d'une justice haineuse au
nom de l'humanité comme le dit robert
badinter
faut-il donc libérer un criminel contre
l'humanité
ou bien faut-il le maintenir en prison
pour l'exemple et pour la mémoire des
victimes